and the happiest people on earth are
officially
the norwegians
they lots of fresh seafood they live
with breathtaking scenery and the long
dark winters don't seem to dampen their
spirits for the first time norway's
taken the top spot in the united nations
world happiness report it's norway
number one
wow it is not
the weather because it's very cold
but i think it's the nature
and the people it's a free country with
uh
you can speak your mind and yeah we can
appreciate like changes and that we are
we're also content with it
your bitterswer is a psychologist and
happiness researcher he's been trying to
find out what makes people contented
with their lives or not since the 1980s
and why are his own countrymen at the
top of the international ranking
people are more equal here than there
are other places in the world
and that has a lot of benefits to it for
example people trust each other more
when they are on equal footing
and trust we know is a very important
factor for you to try and be comfortable
and satisfied with your life
the northern city of toronso can serve
as an example
the educational system is excellent the
state provides healthcare and
unemployment and poverty are low
jar victor sir works at the arctic
university of toronto the world's
northernmost he asserts that the
positive attitude of people in the high
north plays a big part in their overall
contentment
in some parts of the world you actually
see that the less daylight the more
depression you can observe that is not
the case in in norway so that in
northern norway it seems that
people have found ways of adapting to
the dark period they have
activities they look forward to conduct
during the winter which compensate and
even more than compensate for the dark
period
skiing the national sport was invented
in norway
tonser has plenty of snow on the ground
for six months of the year the northern
lights and the sled dog runs are part of
life
during the short summers many norwegians
love to go hiking with family and
friends the law allows everyone to make
camp and even build a fire in the open
in norwegian it's called almonds retin
that's a very long tradition in norway i
think it's almost a thousand year old
that you are allowed to trespass other
people's property you can even hunt
there but it should be in agreement with
the owner but the owner cannot deny you
accessing it and using it
from the age of two children at this
daycare center in tromso spend their
days outside no matter what the weather
shell campervan co-founded this open-air
daycare center one of many in norway he
believes the key to happiness can be
found in the norwegians closeness to
nature
yes i i really think that
my kids are really happy
more kids play together
get out
partying
beget hem and conrad helgeland live with
their four children not far from tromso
they both have jobs and share the
housework
they make an extra effort to make their
home cozy cozily in norwegian especially
when it's cold outside
i think norwegians are
they like having a cozy home and
candles when it's dark and make nice
food and be with their family and
have a good time
burgett hem is also quite happy that she
doesn't have to worry about her
children's future
[Music]
your vitaso says governments can do much
to enhance the people's happiness but
individuals can too
i think that we need
more attention
uh towards what really matters in our
lives i think actually it's good for
people to reflect a little bit upon
what is important for me what should i
do with my life
and not just go along the flow and
follow what is supposed to be
the road to success norwegians have
their own word for a special kind of
happiness
oota pills to sit in the sunshine and
enjoy a beer during arctic summers with
over 20 hours of daylight norwegians
have plenty of opportunity to experience
these happy moments